oui concernant différentes dans deux
parties pardon tout d'abord 18h50 en
intégralité en exclusivité au viens de
vous dire et en direct également antenne
2 retransmet en effet le discours que
nelson mandela fera à cette occasion
et puis plus tard dans la soirée à 22h10
nous rejoindrons julien clerc pour ce
concert où vous l'avez vue sont réunis
les plus grandes stars internationales
mais une autre opération exceptionnelle
et d'espoir elle aussi poursuit sa route
tout au long de ce week-end pascal nous
vivons à son heure ce lundi patrice
laffont l'a dit il y a un petit instant
nous arrivons sur la route des retours
c'est un point critique
si ce n'est pas encore fait rejoignez
nous soyez prudent le dira jamais assez
l'opération drapeau blanc continue et
maintenant je laisse la parole à daniel
duigou pour un flash info bonjour daniel